Mark: Boo!
*momiplier laughs*
Mark: Did I scare you?
Momiplier: A little bit.
Mark: A little bit?
Momiplier: So what---where---where should I go?
Mark: Oh, you know, around.
Momiplier: Just look around?
Mark: Yeah
Momiplier: I better watch carefully, right?
Mark: Yeah watch carefully
Momiplier: Nobody's here...
Mark: Who's that?
Momiplier: Ooh.
Momiplier: Who are you?
Mark: Who are you?
Momiplier: What are you doing there?
Mark: I dont know..
Momiplier: I'm a momiplier go away!
*laughter*
[ Monster makes the FNAF shrieking noise ]
*Momiplier laughing*
Mark: You weren't watching the-
*even more laughter*
I'm too old for this (she's 54!)
Mark: You get one more try!
then we'll give your-
your poor old heart a rest
*stressful giggles*
Momiplier: Oohh jeez-
Mark: You're good!
Mark: You're doing great!
Mark: Just keep observing
Momiplier: Okay, now-
Mark: Stay focused
Mark: Stay true.
Momiplier: OOH! Something in there!
Mark & Momiplier: [ parroting chants of 'yeah!' ]
Momiplier: I gotcha!
*Power of the Ship gradually increasing in noise*
Momiplier, distressed: Ohhhh yeah!
Mark: You got this mom!
Mark: You got this!
Momiplier: Are you sure?!
Momiplier: Are you sure? [distressed noises ]
Mark: [unaudible]
Mark: [unaudible, again]
Mark: wha - What did you do?
Mark: Control! (?)
Mark: AAH, hey!
Mark: [unaudible v3]
[momiplier screams]
Mark: stay...
Mark: Okay, now click and hold that.
Momiplier : Okay.
Momiplier: Hold it, hold it, hold it, yes, I'm holding, I'm holding, what is gonna happen, what's gonna happen?
[Mark in background constantly saying  good, good,  you good]
Momiplier: EYYYY  EEH  EEE YOOP
[blast]
[momiplier's screeching noises]
Momiplier: We did it!
both: Yaaayh
[applause]
Momiplier: Sooo....
Momiplier: See? Momiplier. Girl scary, right?
Mark: I know.
Momiplier: Yeah
Momiplier: BOOM, hehehehehehehe
Hey, lovin' this
eeysthetic right now
l o o k    a t    t h a t    b u t t
[laughter]